say in the balloon we've got a sample of
xenon now Xenon's one of the inert gases
but it's one of the inert gases just
right the way down the bottom in the
period so it's really really dense so
what that means is that the gas
molecules themselves are really really
large really really heavy
so in principle they'll sink so xenon is
one of my favorite elements it's it's a
gas but you can liquefy it really quite
easily so we've done an experiment here
we filled this building with xenon now
xenon is very expensive so there's about
40 pounds with the xenon in this balloon
right now yeah so we're going to do this
experiment and we're going to see if it
sinks and I think you'll agree that it
does sink quite quickly this is an
old-fashioned xenon lamp the xenon in
its Nerds bulb and you put a large
voltage through here and the xenon gets
very hot and shines out as a very bright
light it looks black here because the
electrodes get so hot that the metal has
evaporated but xenon itself is colorless
but just to show you how dense it is
we've got a similar balloon but you'll
notice in this balloon is much much
higher filled so it's much much bigger
now this is one that we've just blown up
with air so this is a more modern xenon
lamp of the sort of lamp that is used in
very powerful spotlights for example on
tanks to illuminate that's military
tanks to illuminate the target and the
window here is made of aluminium oxide
and all the light comes out as a really
very powerful beam so let's see if we
can compare the rates at which these two
balloons will sink so we can look at the
comparative densities ready
now that's a really clear demonstration
to show how dense the xenon gas itself
is xenon can also be used to make very
powerful lasers and in the 1980s when
Ronald Reagan did then American
president started his so-called Star
Wars program to try and destroy rockets
in space there was a plan to put xenon
chloride lasers into space and the price
of zine Xenon's it literally rocketed so
that scientists like me just couldn't
afford to do research when we moved on
to cheaper materials like carbon dioxide
but xenon exists in the air and when
people liquefy air they first all
separate the nitrogen and then the
oxygen for and at the end they're left
with the noble gases argon Krypton and
xenon so it is made from the air and one
of the problems with this price rise of
xenon was that at the same time as there
was a bigger demand for xenon there was
a downturn in the steelmaking industry
which uses a lot of oxygen so the
chemical plants that were or the
refrigeration plants that were making
zine oxygen was switched off so there
was a smaller supply of xenon that'll be
the air